who asked you to do that was that Jimmy
Kimmel Jimmy Kimmel oh boy he said Helen
would you do this I said yes before it
was like a couple of days before
actually but I thought how addictive of
course I've got to do that that's gonna
be so ridiculous see you up there genius
mind I mean what did you guys talk about
going up on stage together that must
have been incredible though I it was it
was you know obviously Jane Fonda has
been very much a part of my life for my
whole life actually and you know someone
who was a huge star when I really wasn't
but I did turn to her just before the
cut the thing went up and I just said I
just want to tell you how incredibly
honored I am really to be here it's it's
an amazing experience for me because I
have you know what to do and been
impressed by you for my whole life so
it's amazing for me to be standing here
next to you right now a baby coming the
rollway
and you know the princess you've met
them so what does it mean for you to see
Prince Harry now marrying the love of
his life Megan Marco that must be
exciting let's hope she's the love of
his life
you know absolutely she's I think she is
so cool I think she she's behaved as I
say impeccably I've got right from the
beginning right for when they started
going out together and you know I think
he's a very lucky boy he's a lovely boy
I've met him young man I should say but
both of them absolutely charming natural
easy generous you know they look you
straight in the eye and they talked to
you and I've only observed her from a
distance like everybody else but I've
been really impressed by her yeah and
L'Oreal does such an intelligent woman
that inspiring you inspires so many
people so God makers what do you do for
yourself will tell yourself to have that
confidence in yourself I think the trick
is to take it away from yourself saying
oh I'm so useless and I'm ugly and I'm
ugly and I'm everything it's like what's
the constant word there it's I'm I'm me
me so I think the best way to deal
with like a self-confidence is actually
to go out from yourself and put yourself
in the rightful place in the universe
which is not the center of the universe